To Fox News and right wing media are very
desperately putting together a concerted effort
to turn these wacky corona virus protesters
into what is essentially a new Tea Party.
And as you may be aware, there have been these
mass gatherings, protests in states where
people are demanding everything be opened
back up, regardless of safety, regardless
of infection risk.
And Fox News has been promoting them as if
these are heroes who are doing this rather
than simply people who are creating a public
health problem.
Here's Judge Jeanine, a Fox News host praising
one protester on her show over the weekend.
Debbie Dingell, who is the senator, didn't
have nice things to say about you guys.
And I was rather shocked.
Here she is, a representative of your state,
criticizing this this peaceful protest.
And it was pretty peaceful, saying it was
inexcusable.
What what are Michigan's reaction to her?
Well, I can tell you, look at Michigan.
Look, it's the nation.
What we've done with Operation Gridlock and
has ignited a fire that has spread across
this entire nation.
Arizona, Pennsylvania, Texas.
I mean, today, New York, great example of
gridlock.
People rising up all across this nation.
All right.
And you know, a lot of people are very proud
of you, Michonne, and what you've done and
let me just say, Debbie Dingell is a congresswoman
and not a senator.
Of course, the issue isn't actually whether
the protests are peaceful.
It's whether the protests are putting people
at health risk.
And of course, they are.
And as Caleb Carma wrote in Vanity Fair this
Monday, the network and its most important
viewer, Donald Trump, are amplifying the voices
of a small but vocal minority protesting state
lockdown orders.
They are turning these protesters much like
they did around the Tea Party into a principled
constitutional conservative movement.
So remember that with the Tea Party, if you
were following politics at the time of the
Tea Party, you had a movement that knew very
little in terms of facts.
But that didn't stop them from loudly and
indignantly and furiously in many cases, asking
for policies that would be bad for them personally.
But they were policies that their side decided
that they want lower taxes for the rich is
one that comes to mind.
You have a very similar situation here, people
who lack facts both about the virus and about
economics and about just about everything.
But they are advocating for reopening, which
would be bad for them in the medium term because
the case spikes will occur and more people
will get sick and more people will die.
And over the medium term, it will actually
be worse for the economy, not better.
And you have Fox News and right wing media
cheerleading them.
Tucker Carlson hosted a protester as well
and thanked them for their service in these
protests.
Rush Limbaugh cheered on the protesters by
citing these examples of American bravery
and sacrifice from the past that have nothing
to do with what these protesters are doing.
Donald Trump, of course, tweeted over the
weekend, liberate Minnesota, liberate Michigan,
liberate Virginia and save your great
Second Amendment.
It is under siege.
Trump adviser Stephen Moore, who has been
a vector of disinformation lately, Stephen
Moore called these protesters modern day Rosa
Parks, which really makes no sense.
And in fact, a Washington Post columnist back.
Max Boot, with whom I don't agree that often
says that it's not Rosa Parks that they should
be likened to.
It's really Typhoid Mary.
That would be a more apt comparison.
Typhoid Mary.
Good.
Google her Google Typhoid Mary if you're interested
in this.
Typhoid Mary was an Irish woman believed to
have infected 51 people with typhoid fever,
believed to be the first person in the United
States identified as an asymptomatic carrier
of typhoid fever.
That seems like a more apt comparison than
Rosa Parks to these protesters.
And we have to work really hard to prevent
right wing media from turning these people
into heroes or
into martyrs or into whatever they are.
The problem, not the solution.
And as usual, in Trump world, in Fox world,
everything's backwards noticed.
By the way, these suppose a small government,
constitutional conservatives, they're not
protesting the multi-trillion dollar bailout
put together by Trump, which certainly doesn't
sound like small government.
Not a peep from them about it.
There's nothing smart or patriotic about the
protests.
And yet you see them doing that and not protesting
trillions of dollars in government spending.
It's a spectacle and it's a pathetic one at
that.
But it's dangerous no matter what.
We finally have a real enemy.
That we should all be united against, we could
all be united against.
And you have people acting in ways that are
essentially supportive of the virus.
The way they are behaving spreads the disease.
It's a level of stupidity and irresponsibility
that should really
scare us.
But also the incoherence of the ideology should
scare us as well.
Government is bad.
So vote Trump because he's an outsider.
But government is now good.
So we should all support Trump and everything
he does, even if he is taking and exercising
more power than we would have ever said.
The office of the presidency should have because
Trump is the best.
But now government's bad because the governors
are telling us to stay home.
But wait a second.
Government's good because Trump is handing
out trillions and trillions of dollars that
in the past we would have said is a complete
overreach for government to be involved in.
It's incoherent.
They're wrong, ignorant, dangerous, whatever
word you want to apply to it.
The effect is more people
are
going to die.